hey guys what's up I'm Alana welcome to
my youtube channel i am currently
covered in blood and dut because I just
finished cosplaying it's easier if we
just glossed right over that that is a
thing that is just part of this video
because trying to work full-time and
make youtube videos once a week and DJ
on the side and go to this gym everyday
is not very glamorous what today is mine
November highlights slash favorites
video where I talk about all the movies
and games and stuff that I played in
November we gonna be talking about this
on it to watch talks to the new Harry
Potter movie the arrival and black
mirror I'm gonna start right off with
black Mara because I technically came
out last month but I only got to watch
it this month for those who don't know
black Mara was a UK TV series it's
basically like modern Twilight Zone but
all focused around technology the reason
that I really loved majority of the
first two seasons is because it provides
a kind of thought-provoking political
commentary or presents a possible future
the new season of flat Mara has that a
lot less season three is six episodes
long some episodes are really really
well shot but for the most part it felt
a lot more like entertainment than
anything even close to being as
thought-provoking or even as challenging
as the first two seasons whoa that's an
episode that's about blackmail that's
just about blackmail it left that
episode thinking like yeah that was
interesting in really [ __ ] up okay so
it doesn't make it bad television but
it's definitely not what I wanted or
expected after the first two seasons of
black Mara which is a little bit
disappointing to me because I loved that
show next up was Dishonored 2 game of
the year from the aesthetic which we at
IGN are referring to as whale Punk -
Emily's motivations as a character - the
incredibly intricate and almost
overwhelmingly large level design I
adore just wanted to there are multiple
entry ways to every single building that
you see and it's often the most obvious
one is kind of hardest one this is very
hot in general I'm terrible at it I die
a lot
but I think that's part of the appeal
every single time that I die I jump
right back in try to self again but the
way that I'm playing and is basically as
soon as someone finds me and tries to
attack me I'll try and knock them all
out but by cohn I'll just kill them I'm
not doing save scumming it's a beautiful
game
that had surprises and twisted
challenges around every single kona next
up let's talk about fantastic beasts and
where to find them what I took away from
it was that it was very pretty
I loved the pots that featured the
beasts specifically and learning more
about them was really fun but pretty
much every other plot point around that
just was shoehorning I feel like I would
have liked fantastic beasts and where to
find them better if it was a VR
experience but those who seen it if I
could go inside the main characters
briefcase and walk around and look at
this basically zoo of exotic weird
magical creatures that he has that would
be amazing so yeah it was fun to watch
but as a narrative or ism literal movie
it kind of felt like a waste of time
please still make it into a VR game
though because that would be amazing
next up let's talk about watchdogs - I
haven't played very much of this should
say that I feel like I'm gonna save
watchdogs - kind of food
december-january when things are a
little bit quieter because you know it's
big open world game I really like Marcus
Holloway I liked him from the initial
trailers I still really liked him
San Francisco looks awesome but just
from the brief time that I did play it
there wasn't a lot to draw me in so
maybe this is the kind of thing that is
dumb and fun and it's just why I'm
playing dishonored right now compared to
that it's like it seems too light being
so invested in dis on it to jump to
something like watchdogs which is you
know creative and funny and it is funny
there are some pots that I think you're
a little cheesy and I don't know whether
it's trying to be a parody or if it's
being serious with the characters of
almost lame but not quite it's confusing
I guess that's probably partly because
they move very very far away from aid
and peace that whole disaster but yeah
very hard to compete with Dishonored
when that's all I want to play right now
and last but not least is a rival I had
not seen any trailers or anything going
into this movie so aside from knowing it
was about aliens I knew nothing so I'm
going to keep it the same for all of you
it is a very very smart incredibly
well-written incredibly well paced
beautifully shot spectacular sound
design masterpiece of a thing you're an
action movie lover then it's that's it's
not what it's going for but everything
that it does do it does incredibly well
it is just
very hard floor and I usually really
don't like jeremy renner but I actually
really liked his performance in this as
well all right you guys that's the stuff
that I checked out in November wasn't a
huge month for me game wise because I
did go to Australia for two weeks so I
was hanging out with my family as much
as I could but I did also want to give a
shout out to the Paddington movie on
Netflix because it's absolutely amazing
can I add Thanksgiving to my November
favorites is my first time eating
pumpkin pie and apple sauce and [ __ ]
that Americans referred to it's biscuits
it was really fun obviously I spend it
with friends because families in
Australia we don't have Thanksgiving but
who's cool it was very similar to an
Australian Christmas and I do have to
give a shout out of course to the people
who supported my channel after the last
video we have de Ville Westphal
hopefully I pronounced that right
Michael crows Oh who some people have
asked about this so I mentioned that the
support my channel feature only works in
certain countries I think it's only
three countries Michael said that using
a VPN to donate box so if you want to do
that you can support my channel thing is
below some videos and on my about page
it's basically like a tip jar your
favorite youtubers so thank you so much
to Michael I seriously appreciate that
another one from oh boy Cowell
mm-hmm Susan mix go ski this isn't
Makowski this is s zy m CZ y KO w sk i
don't know how to say your name but
thank you and another one from legend
reborn 3 thank you guys so much again
it's the best so thank you guys so much
for watching I love you all and I will
see you guys next time
hi